dass so ein mob überhaupt auf den
gedanken kommt einfach so rein zu rennen
rein rennen zu wollen in das deutsche
parlament ja das herz der deutschen
demokratie und das dann auch nur so
wenige deutsche polizisten davor stehen
um das zu schützen haben ihnen diese
beiden fakten angst gemacht
na ja ich hatte schon für problematisch
dass es anscheinend menschen gibt die
hier nicht nur ihre meinung vertreten
sondern die aus einem massiv rechten eck
kommen oder die hier mit antisemitischen
parolen auch arbeiten das ist etwas das
lehnen wir zutiefst ab und ich habe
daher auch unseren österreichischen
innenminister gebeten herauszufinden ob
ihr auch österreicher beteiligt waren
denn falls ja dann wollen wir eine
bestmögliche kooperation mit den
deutschen behörden um diese menschen
auch zur verantwortung zu ziehen
haben sie schon hinweise darauf dass
ihre landsleute teilweise dort auch
vertreten waren
es gibt hinweise dass einige an dieser
demonstration teilgenommen haben
jetzt gibt es festzustellen ob sie sich
auch strafrechtlich etwas zuschulden
kommen haben lassen aber wenn ja dann
gehört es auch sanktioniert ganz klar ob
das jetzt in österreich oder in
deutschland stattfindet das wollen wir
nicht